I'm delighted to welcome to the Google plex,
Kelly mcgonigal,
a health psychologist at Stanford University and the author of a new book,
the willpower instinct.
So in life,
sometimes we struggled with choices and accomplishing goals and we often believe
that sheer willpower will get us there,
but much of what we believe and know about bill far could actually be wrong.
Or that's what Kelly discovered in working with students at Stanford University
where she teaches at Stanford University School of Medicine and the Stanford
Center for compassion.
So she created a course called the science of willpower at Stanford School of
continuing studies and became one of the most popular courses at the school and
went onto become a hugely successful blog at psychology today.
And now a book which you can get your hands on a bend of the stock and Kelly's
ACFE.
If she has her way,
it'll soon be an action figure and an action movie too.
So today Kelly's going to talk about how we can accomplish the array of goals
that we often struggle to get done.
It might be a healthier lifestyle.
It might be a life of greater productivity or sometimes something as simple as
having waited for six months.
Finally,
finally clearing out the closet.
So please help me welcome Kelly mcgonigal.
Thank you.
Hello.
Well,
I've been giving a lot of talks this last month and a lot about new year's
resolutions.
I have to say this is the first place I've taught where there was apparently a
healthy code resolution going on.
Is that right?
Did I see the signs right?
So who's still keeping their healthy code resolution?
Anyone?
Good?
Congratulations.
We've got some willpower.
Um,
why don't you tell me,
just sort of get things rolling.
Tell me something that has challenged your willpower today.
Anyone getting up on time?
Getting up on time.
Washing the dishes.
Okay.
So we've got to kind of,
I will power challenges.
Something you have to make yourself do,
even though be a little bit easier.
Just not do it.
Something else.
Yeah.
Doing Yoga for back pain.
Well,
I'm glad to hear that.
Were you at my talk two years ago about Yoga for pain?
That's great.
Uh,
yeah.
Another,
I will challenge something else.
Yeah.
Okay.
So an example of I won't power.
There are all these links you could follow.
You could just click and get lost down the link hall.
Uh,
and you have to find the ability to resist that temptation.
Maybe one or two more.
Oh,
anything back row.
And he will power challenges.
How about lunch options for today?
Yeah.
Have you had your lunch yet?
Are you
great?
Yeah.
So we make lots of decisions every day about what to eat and what to do.
Okay.
Well these are all great examples of willpower challenges.
And I want to just start with a little definition.
My definition of willpower,
willpower challenge,
and I define a willpower challenge as something that is basically a competition
between two parts of yourself.
Neuroscientists are famous for saying that even though we have one brain,
we actually have two minds and we are completely different people depending on
which mind is active or which systems of the brain are more active.
And so willpower challenges,
anything where those two versions of yourself have competing goals.
So,
for example,
there may be part of you that really wants to eat a candy bar for your snack.
And then there's a part of you that actually has some longer term goals.
You're thinking how you're thinking weight loss,
you're thinking bikini season,
whatever.
And maybe the banana seems like the better snap.
And again,
both of these choices,
uh,
you might be drawn to buy different,
different parts of your mind are two different versions of yourself.
And one of the things that has really influenced my work with willpower is
thinking about it in terms of what's going on in the brain.
And we're going to talk about that a little bit today.
The fact that you could be the very same person,
but depending on your mindset,
depending on your energy,
depending on your stress levels,
your brain is going to meet this willpower challenge in a different way.
And you're going to end up making,
you know,
one choice today and one choice tomorrow.
Um,
so as mentioned,
uh,
this book is based on the class that I teach at Stanford called the science of
Willpower.
Those are our actual students.
I'm not sure what I said that was funny,
but those are actual signs of willpower students.
And,
um,
I created this course because I was going around trying to teach people how to
be more productive,
how to improve their health.
And everywhere I went people said,
oh,
we know we're supposed to do that stuff already.
We just don't want to do it.
And there was this really interesting fundamental gap between what people wanted
and what they thought they wanted,
that his people were very identified.
Um,
you could say with this version of the cells,
people felt like deep down they were the person who wanted the candy bar and
this other person who wanted the banana.
Like,
who is that?
That's not really me.
Um,
and I realized that people didn't just need to know what is the right thing to
do or the healthy thing to do or tips for stress management and productivity.
They needed to feel like this person and they needed to know how to be that
person as the default rather than walking around,
always feeling like they had to.
They had to uh,
resist this core self that only wants immediate gratification or never want to
do anything difficult.
Okay.
So that's how the class came about.
What his clicker.
There we go.
Okay,
great.
So I thought today since this is a class based on science that I would share
with you five of my favorite experiments from the class and from the book.
And I chose experiments that I like because they use tiny interventions,
really,
really small interventions to shape people's behavior.
And they have very large outcomes.
And I think this is the kind of thing many of us are looking for.
One small change we can make,
whether it's a change in how we think or change in the way that we're
approaching a willpower challenge that can have huge payoffs down the road,
making it easier to do what it is we really deep down want,
even when it's sometimes difficult or part of us doesn't want.
Okay.
So let's start with the first experiment.
How many,
you guys sometimes feel like this guy,
I know at least one of you only had three hours of sleep last night.
Yeah.
So it turns out that when you're this version of yourself,
every willpower challenge is more difficult.
And the first intervention,
and I want to tell you about is actually a sleep intervention.
The main intervention was trying to help people sleep more or sleep better.
And it was people who had a very,
very serious willpower challenge.
These are people who were recovering from addiction to drugs and they were in a
substance abuse recovery program and half of the people in the standard care
were assigned to take a mindfulness meditation training that was designed to
help them improve their sleep or sleep more.
And so the first thing I want you to take a look at on this graph,
this is minutes of sleep per night and you're going to thank,
this is insanely optimistic,
I know,
but,
uh,
that everyone's starting around seven hours and we're going to improve on seven
hours and that that probably seems impossible dream.
Okay?
So everyone in the group was starting around seven hours.
And with the researchers found was that just doing a little bit of meditation,
everyday breath focused meditation,
uh,
increased sleep time to just over eight hours a day and the control group had a
little bit of deterioration to slightly less than seven hours of sleep at night.
Okay.
Now that's not the interesting finding.
I mean,
it is nice to know that if you meditate for a few minutes a day,
you will sleep better and get more sleep.
But what's interesting is how that,
that change in sleep time then made these recovering addicts,
uh,
impervious to relax,
they were stronger against relapse.
And this is a very high correlation 0.7,
Oh,
the increase in sleep time predicted resistance to relapse with a correlation of
0.7.
Oh,
getting one more hour of sleep at night suddenly made it a lot easier for these
recovering addicts to resist the temptation of falling off the wagon.
And interestingly,
the,
um,
the number,
I never know it's going to bounce off the screen.
Right?
I should point at the screen.
You guys are tech experts.
Uh,
the number of minutes per day that people meditated also predicted resistance to
relapse.
So there were really two things going on in this intervention.
There was getting more sleep and there was also something about the actual
practice time and it wasn't a lot,
but it was something like 10 minutes a day,
15 minutes a day.
And both of these things,
sleep and meditation,
we're um,
we're giving people more willpower for one of the biggest willpower challenges.
So what does the thing together a little bit about why those two small
interventions,
an hour more sleep or 10 minutes of meditation a day might actually give us more
willpower for any willpower challenge.
What you're looking at here is an image from an FMRI study of what happens to
the brain when you are a little bit sleep deprived.
And most studies use,
uh,
less than six hours of sleep a night as sleep deprived,
which may seem normal to you,
but for most of us that's actually functioning far suboptimal.
Um,
what you're looking at here is a composite of a lot of different people's
brains,
some who are sleep deprived and some who are not.
And we're going to slice the brains.
So imagine me standing this way and we're going to have one of those like meat
slicers and we're going to slice down the head and just start taking sections
off and looked down the middle.
And so where you see these yellow spots,
that's the front of the brain right about here or right about here that where my
brain pointing that way,
uh,
and yellow means that this area of the brain is under activated when you have
less than six hours of sleep at night or this area of the brain is unable to do
it to job as efficiently.
And the,
uh,
the red areas are areas that are more activated,
um,
sort of mid brain regions that are associated with basic impulses and instincts.
So when you're getting less than six hours of sleep at night,
your brain is actually unable to,
uh,
to recruit the systems of the brain that you need to be that better version of
yourself.
This area of the brain.
I love this image because it's,
it's like here's the,
where the balance is way.
Do I want the weight loss or do I want the chocolate bar?
And this area of the brain right here is basically keeping track of your goals
and uh,
it's sort of hard job.
It's heavy lifting.
It needs to do is to remember longterm goals,
uh,
core values.
And when it is unable to do that,
when it's under fueled or when it's underactive,
your brain thinks all it really wants.
All you really want is the chocolate bar or to procrastinate or to follow that
link through or to not bother doing your yoga exercises.
And so in some key way,
the ability to remember who you are and what your big goals are,
is dependent on the ability of this area of the brain to use energy.
Well.
And sleep deprivation is one of the main things that can get in the way of that.
And I think that's one of the reasons why this small sleep intervention ended up
helping people resist relapse to drug addiction because they now had brains that
were better fueled to remember their goals,
to stay clean and sober.
Um,
and it's not just sleep that impacts,
uh,
the physiology of your brain,
how well your brain uses energy.
There are a couple of other things that seem to really,
um,
strengthen the ability of the brain's frontal regions to do what they're
supposed to do to help you control impulses and find your motivation.
And a,
here are the four things from the research that seem to do it to make your brain
a kind of willpower machine.
One is sleep,
as I mentioned,
and hopefully there's going to be one thing on this list that you're not
currently doing that you're willing to do because you don't have to do all four.
Uh,
so getting a little bit more sleep really makes the,
the prefrontal cortex better able to regulate those systems of the brain that
direct you towards temptation and immediate gratification and meditation also.
And both meditation and physical exercise has been shown not only to make your
brain more efficient at using these self control systems,
but they actually make these systems bigger and better connected to the regions
that they are supposed to be controlling.
Um,
and again,
it's,
it's can be a very quick time course to see these benefits.
People who meditate maybe 10 minutes a day after a couple of months,
the brains look different.
These regions are bigger and better connected.
Uh,
people who work out on a regular basis who used to be sedentary.
Again,
studies show that in as little as a couple of months or regular workouts,
their prefrontal cortices are bigger and denser and better connected.
Um,
and so these are two of the things you can do that actually train the physiology
of your willpower.
And the last thing,
uh,
that the research suggests is what you eat has a very big influence on whether
or not your brain is able to be this better version of yourself.
There's something about having a big,
big spikes in blood sugar levels and then big drops in blood sugar levels that
really screws up how the brain uses energy.
Um,
and you need your brain to be like an energy efficient machine if you're going
to be walking around the world in that kind of better you mindset rather than
the,
that kind of basic impulse you.
Uh,
and so research shows that shifting to eating a more plant based diet actually
changes the way the brain functions and has a lot to do with what's going on
with your blood sugar levels.
And so these are all things that we sometimes think of as requiring willpower,
right?
We think,
okay,
I have to sit down and force myself to meditate.
I have to work out,
I have to say no to the doughnut and eat something.
You know,
that has fiber in it for breakfast.
But we rarely think about the fact that that actually not doing these things.
Maybe part of what makes it so difficult to begin.
And there's a kind of a,
a curve where when we first started,
it feels like we're using willpower.
But everything on this list that takes a little bit of willpower to begin with
ends up giving you back far more willpower than the take and not just for these
challenges.
It's not just that exercising makes it easier to exercise.
Studies show that exercising makes it easier to eat,
right,
to not spend too much money to stop procrastinating,
to pay better attention.
All of these things have a kind of global training effect on what you could
think of as your willpower muscle.
It was,
was there a question up front or a comment?
So the question is why does it say low-glycemic and plant base?
There's actually more evidence that a Vegan Diet does this better than a diet
that is low-glycemic and includes animal products.
But I'm not sure that that's entirely realistic for everyone.
So I think you can kind of pick your,
your uh,
which way you're willing to go with that both low-glycemic and plant based help.
But if you look at just the physiology of it,
there's more evidence for the plant based Diet.
Okay.
So let me go onto the next experiment.
The first experiment was just get some more sleep.
Second experiment.
I want you to think about a recent setback you had or a kind of a willpower
failure.
Maybe it was not eating the healthy thing at lunch.
Maybe it was not doing your exercise in the morning.
Maybe it was spending all morning long following links that had nothing to do
with your project.
Okay.
So I want you to think of a recent time when you has some kind of willpower
failure.
Does anyone need to borrow one of mine?
Yeah,
you guys got one?
Okay.
So my question for you is,
do you,
do you think that feeling bad about that,
presumably feeling maybe a little bit of regret,
a little bit of guilt about it,
a little bit of self criticism about that.
Does that help us improve next time?
Does that,
can that be a real source of future willpower?
Raise your hand if you think that feeling bad can actually be a real source of
willpower to improve next time ends up.
And how many of you think that that feeling bad is actually going to be a
further drain on willpower?
Yeah.
Great.
Maybe some of you have read that chapter in the book.
Um,
so I want to talk now about some of the research that tends to surprise people
the most.
When I first started teaching this class,
this was the research people argued with,
like literally I couldn't get them to be quiet in the classroom because they
were so convinced this could possibly be true.
This is a study looking at whether it's better to let yourself off the hook for
your mistakes in terms of preventing future willpower collapses.
And so this particular study I'm going to talk about in a little more detail,
broadened people who were trying to manage their weight and eat healthy and they
gave them an immediate willpower failure.
They showed up for the study and they were forced to eat a donut and they even
had to choose the flavor of donut they were going to eat.
So they would feel really complicit in this willpower failure.
And they had to drink a whole glass of water too so they'd feel a little bit
uncomfortably full.
Okay,
so we have everyone died or is here having it now a willpower failure.
They just ate this donut.
Uh,
and then the next part of the study is a taste test where they're given a lot of
different types of candy and they're sad,
you know,
um,
we want you to evaluate all these candy,
so please just eat as much as you need to,
as much as you want so that you can evaluate these candies.
Uh,
and of course these candies were all pre wade so that experimenters could find
out exactly how much candy the dieters eight after they had blown their diet
with a donut.
And in this particular study,
the researchers had a hypothesis.
They thought that that the guilt that dieters experience when they fall off
their diet actually really undermines future self control.
And so they wanted to create an intervention that would basically get rid of the
guilt and shame that people feel when they make a mistake.
And so in this study,
half the dieters were randomly assigned to receive a special letting themselves
off the hook message.
So between the donut eating and the taste test and experiment or came in and
said very simple,
they said,
by the way,
we've,
we've realized now that some people in this experiment feel guilty after eating
the doughnut.
Okay?
So there was an opportunity for people to recognize they might be feeling
guilty.
Second part of the message,
um,
we want you to remember that actually everyone indulges sometimes and we asked
you to do it.
So there's a kind of putting it in a broader perspective.
And the last part of the message was a simple plea.
Please don't be too hard on yourself about it.
Okay?
So very simple.
You might be feeling guilty.
Remember,
everyone does it.
Don't be hard on yourself about it.
And then they went onto the taste test.
And what the researchers found was that the women who had been given the,
um,
the self forgiveness message,
eight less than half as much candy as women who had not been told don't worry
about it.
It's not a big deal,
which is exactly the opposite of what most people think.
Most people think.
You make a mistake,
you have a willpower failure,
and you start saying nice things to yourself about it.
That this could only lead to disaster,
that would lead to licensing even more indulgence.
And yet that's exactly the opposite of what was found in this study.
And not just this study,
but in a lot of different studies.
Now,
this is one of the,
sort of the strongest pieces of a theory we have and willpower research right
now.
That is the harder you are on yourself when you have a willpower failure,
the more likely you are to have the same failure again.
And the bigger it's gonna be when you do.
For example,
one study took a look at,
um,
at problem drinkers and had them keep track of how much they were drinking and
how bad they felt the morning after.
And what they found is that the people who were the most self critical and felt
the most ashamed or guilty about drinking the night before,
wanted to drink more immediately when they woke up and also drank more that
night.
And the next,
there was something about the self critical nature of the shame and the guilt
that was driving people back to the very thing they felt bad about.
Same has been shown for addictions,
including quitting smoking.
You know,
you have that first relapse and the more you beat yourself up about it,
the more you now need to be comforted with something.
Probably the very thing that you're feeling bad about because that's probably
why you do it in the first place.
Same has been shown for gambling.
The more people feel guilty,
uh,
and self critical about losing money,
the more likely they are to borrow money and try to win it back and end up
losing more.
And even for procrastination.
So you may not have any kind of addictions.
Um,
but even for procrastination,
research shows that the harder someone is on putting some,
uh,
the hardest someone is on themselves or putting something off the longer they
procrastinate the next time.
And all of this has to do with the basic fact that when we are feeling stressed
out and guilty and ashamed,
that is a state that puts us into the version of ourselves,
the mindset that is much more susceptible to immediate gratification,
temptation and anxiety.
It's,
it's basically the biological opposite of what needs to be happening in your
brain and body to your longterm goals and to be that other version of yourself
that what we would call the willpower version of yourself.
And as soon as you start piling on the guilt and the shame,
your brain switches into that other mode in which now everything's going to be
more tempting,
including procrastinating or including smoking or drinking.
So I just wanted to give you a sense of wow,
what it would be like to give yourself a self compassionate message is going to,
I said this was a tiny intervention,
this doughnut study,
and this is basically all it was.
And there are a number of programs now that are teaching people how to write
these messages for themselves,
uh,
and to literally have them scripted for the moment.
They fail for the moment that they procrastinated and they're late again or for
the moment they had that cigarette when they hadn't smoked in a week.
Uh,
and to be able to,
with this message out as a way of not falling down that hole that we often fall
into.
So the three steps of this message is the first is mindfulness of what you're
thinking and feeling.
Uh,
noticing that you're feeling guilty or noticing that you're feeling self doubt
or self critical,
um,
maybe angry at yourself and actually allow yourself to see those feelings.
Because a big reason that people go from feeling guilty to giving and again is
that they just want to get rid of that feeling.
It's so kind of overwhelming and they want to distract themselves from it with
something that is going to get them into further trouble.
And then the second step is this common humanity.
Uh,
one of the reasons that it is hard to find our motivation and our willpower is
we start to feel like there's something uniquely broken with us.
There's something about who we are that is wrong and weak.
And that mindset makes it very difficult to tap back into your motivation or
your strength.
And so this,
uh,
this message of common humanity is basically saying to yourself,
you know what?
This is part of the process of change.
This is how things get done.
Sometimes we procrastinate,
sometimes we fall off the wagon.
Everyone is imperfect and to recognize it,
this is not saying anything about who you are.
It's saying something about the process and what matters is how you respond
afterward,
not the fact that it happened at all.
And then this last step is encouragement over criticism.
And if you were to think about someone you were mentoring,
you know,
some of you probably have mentees here or interns or you think about a child
that you care about or dear friend,
what would you say to them when they had a setback?
And to say that to yourself,
it might be reminding yourself of your goal.
It might be reminding yourself of the big picture rather than the sort of the,
the micro picture in which you feel like a failure.
Uh,
and to do that rather than the voices we often have in our head that are saying
things like,
oh,
why did you do that again?
You're so stupid.
You're never going to change.
And to actually start to talk to yourself a little bit in the second person as
if you were good for them.
And research shows that,
that this particular approach,
learning how to talk to yourself in this way is a,
is more effective.
For example,
at quitting smoking,
the nicotine replacement therapy,
uh,
that's how being able to respond to setbacks with self compassion can be want
you to take a look at these circles which go from being totally non overlapping,
two extremely overlapping.
And you're going to decide which of these sets of circles best represents how
you feel about who you are today and who you're going to be,
let's say 30 years from now,
30 years in the future,
or pick a time period that feels right to you.
Okay?
So this is your current self and this is your future self.
30 years from now this means who you are today is really very different than who
you're going to be 30 years from now.
Some overlap,
but actually a lot of change is going to be happening between now.
Who knows?
And then,
uh,
this last set of circles,
this is like,
you know what,
who I am today is probably who I'm going to be in 30 years.
Same me.
Okay.
So you're gonna pick for yourself.
Take another few seconds.
I think where you are on this graph,
actually let's,
let's do like a kind of rolling wave,
cause I'm actually curious if there's a trend being here at Google.
So just put your hand up when you see your circle.
Highlight it.
Who's over here?
Over here?
Over here.
Oh,
you guys are normally distributed.
This is great.
This is over here.
Who's over here and who's over here?
Yeah,
pretty good.
Pretty good.
Oh,
that was great.
Okay.
Um,
so it turns out where you put yourself on this map has a lot to do with some
very important willpower challenges related to health and money and even moral
behavior.
Don't feel too bad if you're at an extreme tail that is not associated with
willpower because I'm going to show you some strategies for being able to get to
the,
uh,
the end that is associated with willpower if you need it.
Okay.
So let me start with the first intervention.
And this was an intervention that,
uh,
that was done here at Stanford University.
And this was using undergraduate students who are very young and it was a
virtual reality experiment were undergraduate students came into the laboratory
and uh,
the researchers had carefully created three d avatars,
uh,
of the student themselves.
So if I came into the laboratory,
I would be meeting a three D Avatar of myself at retirement age.
And it was a really great setup,
um,
in which you can,
you've got all the virtual reality equipment on hearing and seeing and it feels
like you are sitting across the table from your future self and it's set up with
cameras in such a way so that if I move my left hand like this,
it looks like my future self is also moving their hand.
And if I talk it looks like my future self is talking back.
And in the study the college students were invited to interview their future
selves to say things like,
Hey,
future Kelly,
what's going on right now?
What's really what's really important in your life right now?
And then they had to answer the question and so they would see there.
I would see future Kelly describing what's important in my life at retirement
age,
uh,
and went on for about an hour getting to know their future selves.
And the reason that I'm the researchers decided to do this intervention is
because they had discovered that most of us feel like our future self is a
stranger and all of you who are on that first half of the distribution sort of
thing like you thinking about the future self and you know,
really know who that is.
It could be really an improvement on this model or it could just be an older
version of this model.
We don't know.
Uh,
but what research has found is that the more you feel like your future self is,
a stranger is different than you,
the less likely you are to do things to protect that future selves health and
happiness.
Because why would you bother saving money for some stranger when you could spend
it today on someone you know and love.
Um,
so in this particular experiment,
uh,
after they had gone to know their future self,
there was some time elapsed cause they didn't want it to be totally obvious what
was going on.
There's some time elapse and they brought people back and had them divvy up
$1,000 in a budgeting task and you know,
they pretended like they were interested in how people make budgeting decisions.
But what they found is that the college students who had met and interacted with
their future self,
uh,
ended up,
allotting more than twice as much money into a retirement account.
Then college students who had not met their future self college students would
nominate their future south were much more likely to want to allot that money to
their present expenses or to,
to some fund splurge.
And,
um,
this research has actually had a lot of impact in the world of retirement
savings and banking.
I just heard an economist recommend last week that we should be trying to
Photoshop pictures of people's future self on every mortgage application or
credit card application so that people would have to really think about the
implications of this.
Um,
I mean,
you could imagine an HR setting right where people are new new employee and
they're asked to make their retirement allocations.
What if they had to interact with their future self first new college students
coming into a first job?
My make a very big difference in their retirement savings down the line.
Okay.
Um,
so that was just one that was the intervention.
That was the experiment.
But I just want to point more broadly to some of the research.
Uh,
looking at that circle graph that I showed you and it turns out that people who,
um,
who believe that there is more overlap,
that they're more closely related to their future self,
have a lot more willpower for different types of willpower challenges.
Oops.
Didn't mean to do that.
So the first thing is they're less likely to procrastinate in general and less
likely to be late.
I mean,
one of my favorite findings from this research is that,
um,
people who had,
who felt like they were less similar to their future self were also more likely
to show up late for the experiment or skip it completely to just blow it off.
Um,
and that was kind of interesting finding.
Uh,
they also are more comfortable or sorry,
are more likely to make ethical decisions at work.
So people who think that the future self is more different,
like a total stranger,
they're actually more likely to feel good about betraying a colleague at work if
it helps them advance in their career,
they're more likely to keep money that they found even when they might have an
inkling of that money belongs to.
And that's kind of an interesting finding because we could,
we could understand retirement future herself.
Um,
but it seems like this,
this,
uh,
ability to disconnect from the longterm consequences of your choices actually
primes you to be that more impulsive self even when it doesn't really have
anything to do with your own longterm benefits.
Um,
and then also looking at real world outcomes.
Not just an experiment,
but you look at what circle people choose and how much money they have,
their assets,
their home,
their debt,
their wealth,
and people who feel closer to their future self actually have,
uh,
have more assets,
are more likely to own their home,
outright,
more money in the bag,
more retirement savings.
And so this is a real world finding,
not just an experiment and they're also more likely to do things that don't have
a pay off immediately like flossing and exercising,
but that will be good to protect their future self.
So with that in mind,
one of my favorite,
uh,
willpower boosting strategies that you can do that doesn't really take any
willpower at all is to get to know your future self.
Uh,
and very,
you know,
you actually hear,
maybe you can do three d avatars,
is that like,
so like a Google project somewhere.
Um,
but,
um,
but so most people can't actually interact with their future self and that high
tech away.
Um,
but it seems like there are other ways that work as well.
And one is to write a letter from your future self to your present self.
And you can do this in a number of different ways.
So one way is to just write to your present self about who you are,
what you're doing,
where you're living,
what you care about.
Or You could even write a more closely defined letter,
uh,
that that looks at some challenge you're dealing with.
Now,
you know,
maybe you're struggling to quit some addiction or uh,
spend time with your family or it's just something that it seems like it's not
working the way you would like it to.
And you could write a letter from your future self thanking your present self
for doing it and describing what it was you did and why it mattered.
Um,
and research suggests that this kind of letter writing from your future self can
actually give yourself more willpower.
Yes,
that is probably not the letter you should.
Right?
So just for the people who are watching this on the video,
the question was,
um,
if you,
if you feel really bad about yourself now cause this,
could this have the opposite effect where you think,
oh my God,
I'm never going to change and your all,
if you're a loser now you're going to always be a loser.
So the letter might be like,
dear loser,
I'm still a loser.
You're still a loser lifestyle that is not the letter.
Um,
actually so research suggests it is better to be optimistic in this letter then
to be pessimistic.
Um,
but at the same time that,
so the key thing about this finding is not so much whether you think you are
going to be exactly the same,
but whether you understand that is going to be the same person having the future
experience and that which actually comes to the,
the second point here.
And so that's actually a different thing.
It's not like are you still going to have all of the same problems and all of
the same neuroses or have you fixed them?
It's not that kind of same self,
different self.
It's,
do you understand that?
Like,
you know how real pain is right now.
If I were to come and punch you,
how much that would hurt.
Do you understand that 30 years from now it's going to hurt if someone punches
you?
And that seems to be the thing that people actually have problems with when they
think about their future selves.
They don't have access to those emotions.
They don't understand that that future happiness is going to be as real and as
important.
And so,
um,
so when you're doing this kind of letter writing or doing this future self
imagination,
the actual critical part is getting to feel like that future self is real and
that it is in some way you that you are going to be the one having this
experience.
And it's not so much whether you think you're going to be the identical person
still listening to the same music you listened to in 1983 or if it's not,
not at that.
Okay.
So here's the second feed yourself exercise,
which kind of gets to that.
And I call this going back to the future.
Um,
and this is the exercise of a mat.
Just imagining yourself in the future.
Studies show that just imagining yourself grocery shopping in the future,
not like,
not anything even relevant to your goals,
but just grocery shopping then ends up helping people make better decisions in
the present moment.
Uh,
that's going to lead to pay off in the future because you can actually imagine
it and you can imagine what would be on the shelf and you know what it feels
like to be pushing a shopping cart.
And there's something about making the future real that gives us more willpower
and an independent of the content,
what you're thinking about.
Um,
but there's also studies showing that you can imagine specific futures related
to your willpower challenge and both good sort of future realities and negative
future realities can be very motivating.
So in one study they had people who wanted to improve their health to imagine
the consequences of not making a change,
like really vividly what that,
what's that going to be like?
What's it gonna feel like 10 years from now if you don't make this change?
And they had another group.
Think about the positive consequences.
I'm making the change and what would that be like and how are you going to feel?
And both of those sort of future thinking ended up increasing the,
the good health behavior in the present.
And so I said you guys have seen back to the future too,
right?
Have you guys seen back to the future too?
You know,
he goes into the future and there's like a really bad future and a really good
future.
Okay.
At some point that that reference is not going to work anymore.
Here's,
um,
so we've got two more interventions in this next intervention.
I just want to take a poll.
So we're talking about visualizing things.
Um,
if you had to guess,
which would be more helpful for finding your willpower,
do you think it's more helpful to imagine or yourself failing or is it more
helpful to visualize and imagine yourself succeeding?
Raise your hand if you think imagining failure is going to be more helpful.
Raise your hand if you think imagining success.
You guys are such a typical Americans.
Okay.
Um,
that's what everyone thinks.
So,
um,
actually it turns out imagining failure is way more helpful than imagining
success.
Not that imagining success is always bad,
but imagining failure is better.
So let me tell you about this one intervention and then some of the theory a
little bit more broadly.
And this particular study,
they took women,
uh,
from young adult to middle age,
a little bit older adults,
uh,
all of whom were not exercising at all and all of whom had the goal to exercise.
And some of those women were randomly assigned to your typical,
it's good to exercise.
Here's why you should exercise.
Now think about your goal and imagine yourself doing it.
Very typical.
And the other half were randomly assigned to a,
what they call it,
an obstacle condition where they had to imagine themselves failing.
They had to ask themselves,
when are you going to not exercise?
What is the opposite going to be?
When is it going to happen?
Uh,
and,
uh,
what are you going to do if that happens?
And they had people write about that every single day.
They had to write out,
when are you going to not exercise?
What are you going to say to yourself that allows you not to exercise?
When's it gonna Happen?
How's it going to happen and what are you going to do when you start to
recognize that stuff happening?
And so the women were becoming kind of detectives have their own failure and
everyday they revise what they were writing based on what they notice.
I didn't exercise because I told myself I'll do it later.
I'll do it later.
Now it's time to go to sleep.
Or I didn't do it because I got so busy at work and then I didn't have my
sneakers.
So I didn't do it.
And they became very clear about how they fail and they were able to predict
future failures from that.
And uh,
here's what the results were.
It had an immediate effect of doubling the amount of time they were exercising.
So the very first week they started to predict their failure in this way,
they doubled to 102 minutes of exercise a week.
And that's getting pretty close to the amount of exercise that you need to have.
Very serious health benefits,
both mental health and physical health.
Uh,
there was a much smaller improvement here in the group of a,
of women who were given the standard you want to exercise.
Exercise is great,
let's do it.
And a 16 weeks,
so four months after that study,
the a women who had been predicting their failure had maintained and we're
exercising twice as much as the women who were in the basic,
let's exercise here,
here's why it's good.
This is the thing that always blows people's minds.
Um,
there is a lot of studies showing that tracking your success leads people to
slack off in the long run,
but nobody believes it.
Um,
so you probably heard how important it is to keep track of your success because
we feel really good when we're able to write down that we did something right.
You know,
you feel really good,
you're like,
yes,
check it off.
Some people make to do lists just so they can check stuff off.
And we know how good we feel when we're able to write down and record our
successes.
And we mistake that feeling good as motivation to do more.
But a,
a number of studies show that when people are reminded of their success and take
note of their progress,
they then are much more likely to do something inconsistent with their goal.
So if you are a somebody,
so for example,
there's studies of dieters where people come in and the experimenter says,
by the way,
we wanted to,
to let you know how much progress you've made on losing weight.
You're this close to your goal,
you've been doing great.
And on the way out of the lab do would you like a chocolate bar?
And women are much more likely to take the chocolate bar if they were reminded
of their success.
The same studies has been shown for procrastination.
You have people keep track and feel good about the progress that they've made on
a task and they're much more likely to choose not to work on it.
And,
uh,
this is,
this is the goal switching hypothesis.
Um,
the idea is that that any willpower challenge is a competition between these two
versions of yourself and they're both you.
And as soon as your mind realizes that one of you is satisfied cause you made
some progress,
the other goal becomes primed and your brain and it becomes more appealing.
So I don't want to say don't keep track of your success because I think in what
I really wanna encourage you to do is both.
Um,
but let me just,
uh,
let me point to a couple of other,
other ideas along this line.
Okay.
So,
um,
about why pessimism can be so helpful because it's profoundly unamerican to be
pessimistic when you have a goal.
And I just wanna encourage you to think about using pessimism is actually a
source of willpower.
Um,
so there's,
there's this kind of finding floating around that people who are most optimistic
about their ability to make a difficult change give up sooner and are most
likely to fail.
And it tends to be because they are shocked by their setbacks.
And to one of the ways that predicting failure it can be helpful is that when it
happens,
it's not like some shock to your system where you can't believe it happened.
It must say something bad about who you are or about your likelihood of success
in the future.
Um,
there's also interesting studies as I mentioned that uh,
optimism while this is both progress and optimism,
but studies show that if you have people make optimistic predictions about what
they're going to do,
they're more likely to then not do it today.
So people who intend to exercise tomorrow are more likely to eat something
unhealthy today and skip the gym.
And even just having people think about what they're going to do in their
future,
it makes people more likely to make a different choice today.
Uh,
and so just knowing that you're going to be just as tempted tomorrow,
you're going to be just as busy tomorrow just to stress out tomorrow turns out
to be an important source of re a willpower today.
Okay.
And then this,
I just had to throw the same cause I think this is one of the funniest findings
in the willpower research that 75% of corporations that are investigated by the
sec for fraud can be tracked back to initial optimism that then people were
unwilling to let go of.
They were so optimistic about profit,
their profit projections that when they met their first setback,
they didn't know what to do and they started to fudge the numbers.
And this is something that we all do with our own goals when we set very high
ideals and then refuse to adjust our expectations based on reality.
And this is something I run into a lot at Stanford.
People say they want to make big change or they have a big goal in mind.
Um,
and they aren't the least bit interested in setting a small goal or a baby step
cause I,
how is that going to ever get me where I want?
So let's go big or go home.
And then when they start to run into problems with that huge level of success,
they kind of hang on to the ideal.
And yet end up doing nothing.
And so you can think of yourself as your own little corporation with goals.
And,
um,
if you find yourself hitting setbacks,
one of the most important things you can do is adjust your expectations,
uh,
and,
and take a really serious look at the process of how failure is working.
Okay?
So here is,
um,
so here's an example from that exercise study that's a little bit broad and out.
And,
uh,
this is basically the writing exercise those women were doing that doubled the
amount of time they were putting into their goal.
Uh,
and they were supposed to do this writing exercise every day.
The first is to identify your goal and what would be a really positive outcome
of that.
So you just,
you gotta get your motivation on board,
right?
And then,
uh,
and then what are you going to do to take it?
So you've set some clearly defined steps and then you spend some time thinking
about how is this not going to happen when and where and why.
Is there anything you can do in advance to prevent that failure?
And when failure happens,
what are you gonna do about it?
And you know,
you don't have to actually make it seven full steps like this,
but it's a very basic exercise that you can do for any goal.
I think of it as being like stress testing a goal.
You have a goal.
You say you're going to do something well now put it to the task and find out
how it's going to break,
how it's going to fail.
Okay,
last intervention.
Let's all do it together unless you have health problems and then you know,
I don't want anyone to pass out or have a stroke.
So,
uh,
if you,
if you are willing to take this challenge,
we're just going to hold our breath for 15 seconds.
Who's got a second hand?
Great.
You're going to time us.
Okay.
Only if you want to do this.
Take a deep breath in.
We'll be your second hand.
Go to take a deep breath out now.
Exhale,
exhale,
exhale.
Exhale it out.
Stop breathing.
Time us
memory.
You can breathe anytime you want to if you need to.
I just want you to notice how this feels.
Three,
two,
one.
Breathe.
Good.
Okay.
So holding your breath,
obviously that's a little bit of a willpower challenge.
Um,
some of you may be,
you need to hold your breath for two minutes to feel it,
but I did not want anyone passing out.
Um,
so would you believe that this ability to hold your breath is one of the best
predictors of people's ability to succeed at difficult goals?
Uh,
it's kind of interesting.
Psychologists call this distress tolerance,
the ability to stay put when things get uncomfortable.
So I want to tell you now about a small intervention that teaches people how to
sort of hold their breath but not exactly how to basically ride out physical
discomfort that gets in the way of making a difficult change.
And to tell you about two different studies that are basically using the same
technique.
So you can kind of pick your willpower challenge here.
The first,
I called the the torture chamber and this was a study of smokers who wanted to
quit but had been unable to and the researchers asked the smokers to abstain
from smoking for 24 hours,
sort of a first challenge and then to come into the laboratory with a fresh
unopened pack of their favorite brand of cigarettes.
So all the smokers show up,
they've got their pack,
they are desperate for a smoke and they even like carbon monoxide tested them to
make sure they hadn't smoked.
So they had all,
they were really,
they were ready for a cigarette.
They all get the seated at a long table and asked to put away all distractions
except for a lighter or a match and their cigarettes.
So you got a bunch of smokers,
now they're ready.
And then the experimenter is about to begin the process of allowing them to
smoke.
And she says through actually a microphone like that,
you hear this voice that says,
take out your pack of cigarettes and everyone does.
They're all excited.
Woo.
Stop.
Okay,
they have to wait two minutes now.
And they're not allowed to do anything except look at their pack of cigarettes.
Pull off the cellophane.
Okay,
great.
Stop.
Two minutes.
They have to wait.
Okay.
Packet.
Or there was patsy.
I don't smoke.
I forget some of these steps.
They're the pack the pack to uh,
and they got the cellophane open.
Okay,
take out a cigarette.
Finally stop.
They have to wait two minutes.
And this goes on.
And every two minutes they,
they're writing down how intense their cravings are and how much they want to
smoke.
But other than that,
they're not allowed to do anything.
Take a cigarette out.
Stop two minutes,
look at the cigarettes.
smell the cigarettes.
Stop two minutes,
put the cigarette in your mouth.
Stop two minutes.
Take out a lighter.
Look at it.
Stopped two minutes.
This went on for over an hour.
Nobody was actually allowed to light the cigarette.
Okay,
so here's what the,
I didn't tell you what the actual intervention was yet half of them before this
happened,
had been taught a technique called surfing.
The urge in which you learned to pay attention to the physical discomfort of
wanting something.
You give it your full attention and you trust that you can tolerate those
physical sensations.
And if you just wait with patients,
they will go away.
That any craving,
any emotion will eventually pass.
If you can just breathe and wait,
wait it out.
That you don't have to act on every impulse or emotion.
So that's the technique they were taught.
They were surfing the urge,
they were imagining those cravings as a wave,
but they were getting on and they were just going to breathe and they knew that
it would eventually end just like a wave.
Uh,
before I tell you the results of this study,
let me just give you the food.
One.
Food one's a little bit different.
They took people who had problems with self control around food,
especially suites,
gave them a clear container of Hershey's kisses,
transparent container.
And they had to carry that box of Hershey's kisses around with them for 48
hours.
And we're not allowed to eat a single one.
And they were all carefully marked little pins scratch.
So that the researchers would know if the ATM and restocked it,
which would not be cool.
Okay.
And they were taught the same technique about how to handle cravings,
how to surf the urge,
allow yourself to feel the craving and yet remember,
you don't need to act on it and the craving will go away eventually.
Okay.
So the results in this study,
the smokers who had been taught how to surf the urge in that,
that one hour torture test,
um,
they ended up reducing their cigarette,
smoked by 40% in the very next week.
Uh,
even though the researchers had not asked them to,
the control group,
did not reduce their cigarettes at all.
And interestingly,
um,
in that the people who had learned to surf the urge there was now no longer a
connection between psychological stress and smoking,
which is actually the,
that's the main connection for a lot of people who are trying to quit.
They're stressed out,
they're anxious and so they need a cigarette.
And in this particular group with this intervention,
uh,
cut that link between stress and giving in probably because they had a tool for
dealing with difficult feelings and emotions.
In this study,
the,
uh,
the people who had trouble with self control around food,
if they were taught to surf the urge zero had a single Hershey's kiss over the
entire 48 hours.
Whereas those who have been given other strategies including distraction,
uh,
ended up much more likely to give in and also really stressed out about it.
Um,
so these are just two different examples of how surfing the urge can give us a
lot of willpower for the things where we need willpower.
You know,
a lot of times I hear people talk about how important it is to build good
habits.
But the reality is sometimes you need strength to do something difficult and
there's no habit in the world that's going to make you not want a cigarette when
you see it or want a donut when you see it or make you want to avoid something
because you're anxious.
There's a real impulse and a real feeling that you need to deal with.
Um,
and this power of acceptance seems to be the best strategy for dealing with
these difficult emotions,
these difficult thoughts and these difficult cravings.
Uh,
and any attempt to kind of push them away or get rid of them backfires.
But being able to ride them out and imagine them as passing experiences that you
don't need to act on has been shown to help a lot of different willpower
challenges,
including the kind of anxiety that leads us to not do things.
We know we should do intrusive thoughts,
you know,
that's a real willpower challenge.
Sometimes our mind goes places we don't want it to go to memories or two things
were imagining or to negative thoughts about ourselves and others and research
shows you can apply the same technique to a negative thought without having to
act on it.
It's been shown to improve weight loss.
It actually this,
this technique of learning how to accept your own cravings tripled the long term
one year weight loss success rate among people who were in a really standard
weight loss program.
It helps substance abuse and it even helps people with schizophrenia.
I mean,
talk about a willpower challenge when you have voices in your own head that you
cannot escape and you're trying desperately to have some kind of normal life and
relationship with the world.
When you've got these voices in your head that are telling you to do something
or not to do something.
And studies show that a schizophrenia who learn to accept their own intrusive
thoughts and hallucinations and delusions like a craving that's not real and you
don't need to act on it,
but it's going to be there and eventually it will pass.
They actually end up being,
uh,
more likely to,
to be out of the hospital bed hospitalized and function normally compared to
people who have not been taught this technique.
Okay?
So
if you want to apply this technique to any willpower,
challenge yourself,
here's what that small intervention would look like for yourself.
Here's what people were taught in a,
in both of those studies.
And the first is this mindfulness to allow yourself to feel what you're feeling
or thinking about your thinking and to actually attend to the experience rather
than immediately tried to escape it.
So if you're hungry,
actually notice like what does hunger feel like in my body?
Where if you're anxious,
what does anxiety feel like in my body right now?
Uh,
and then to actually just breathe,
breathe it out,
use the breath as a source of stability.
You know what you're feeling,
take a few breaths and then broaden your attention out and look for the first
opportunity to recommit to your goal.
That's what they were taught in both the smoking study and in the Hershey's kiss
study.
And it's a technique that you can practice.
It takes like 30 seconds and a and it can help with any sort of willpower
challenge.
Okay.
So just to wrap up five willpower rules and I would just invite you to think if
you heard anything today that might be relevant to your willpower challenge to
give yourself this short dose,
the small dose intervention and a,
and see how it works because that's actually the nature of the class.
And the nature of the book is basically to become a willpower.
Scientists yourself to get some ideas from the research and then test it out.
If you've got a hypothesis,
you can see if it works or not.
Collect your own data.
So those five strategies,
one is to train your willpower physiology by meditating,
by sleeping,
by or by eating a diet that's going to sustain your energy,
forgive yourself the next time you have a willpower setback.
Make friends with your future self.
Kind of think about the future in a way that feels real,
predict your failure even though it's really nice to imagine success.
Really get interested in the process of how you fail.
And then finally think about surfing the urge when you are facing temptation.
And uh,
thank you.
Well you guys,
you waited it out.
You showed a lot of willpower sticking around here.
[inaudible].